- So you mentioned you're the
youngest of 10 kids, right?
10.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
So what, what were your
most random hand-me-downs?
Cause I was the youngest in my family too.
So I lived off of hand-me-downs.
- My brother's Sean was the
Gestapo of hand-me-downs.
So Damon would give us some
clothes and Sean would take all
the clothes and would
never get to me until
he outgrew 'em and by that time
I was out growing up myself.
So I always got random hand-me-downs.
I remember one time I
had my father's draws
and my dad has like a 42 waist.
And like, it might as well went commando.
Cause it wasn't supporting
anything down there.
- (laughs) That's just not good.
- I had a safety pin on them.
It was wind blowing.
I was flapping all over the place.
- (laughs) I love you so much.
You're quickly becoming my favorite guest.
So wait, which sibling
would be least likely
to answer your call right now?
- It would definitely be Keenan because
he never picks up his phone.
Keenan don't care about phone calls.
Like he don't care about
phones so much that
he still has an iPhone one.
I can't FaceTime this man or nothing.
He's still has a rotary
phone in his pocket
with a very long cord.
And Damon.
Damon won't pick up my call either.
None of them won't pick up my call.
- Yeah, I don't pick up my phone call.
(mumurs)
I feel like I'm kind
of the one to, I don't,
I'm kind of the one too,
I don't generally answer them
because I'm usually working.